he is uh along with michael holly
uh the host of brother from another
which is after this show every single
day on nbc sports on peacock joining us
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line is
our friend michael smith how are you
doing michael what up
well lots
right lots going on all right uh i'll
give you the floor on aaron rodgers at
being out he's not vaccinated based on
everybody's uh accounts
um and what do you what what do you
think about all of that michael smith
um i guess the
word i'll hone in on is lie
and
did he lie
well obviously he wasn't completely
forthcoming but from aaron rodgers
perspective i mean i think we all know
that aaron has a reputation as somebody
who likes to fancy himself as the
smartest guy in the room
likes to be clever
and from aaron rodgers perspective
when he was asked are you vaccinated
he answered
honestly
from feeling like hey i did the research
on this homeopathic route yeah i'm
immunized
the right question and i'm not blaming
the reporter for not asking this
question
but if he'd if the right question should
have been in hindsight are you in
complete compliance with the nfl
rules that in order to be considered
fully vaccinated you took modern advisor
johnson johnson
who in their right mind would have asked
that because nobody would have expected
somebody to skirt a direct question
by object skating
which is what he did
i say i like to say i have less of a
problem with his answer to the question
than i do
how he behaved in the months and weeks
since
because for you to go out
masculist
and flop the protocol the way he seems
to have done and furthermore it's not
just aaron rodgers problem my problem is
with
the packers
and the nfl
and whether or not
they turned a blind eye
for fear of pissing him off more than
they already had
to him going to a halloween party just
the other night as john wick great
costume should have had a mask shouldn't
have been there
uh or if he's walking around a facility
in closed quarters without a mask or as
we saw conducting press conferences in
the presence of unsuspecting reporters
without a mask
that's inexcusable and indefensible
and that's what i have a problem with is
that okay there's no crime
in not being vaccinated hell he wasn't
even breaking a rule because it's not an
nfl mandate
but the cover-up the collective cover-up
from rogers from the packers from the
league
that's problematic and that's why he
deserves all the smoke and all the
criticism that he is getting today and
while i wish him the best in terms of
his recovery i hope his symptoms are
mild if not
uh asymptomatic
but i hope he's suffocating on the smoke
that he's getting today because this
that that's that's messed up and i would
use the worst word if i were on radio
with you right now but that's really
messed up for you to conduct yourself as
if you are fully vaccinated knowing good
and damn well that you are not in
compliance with the league which
rejected your
uh your request well i bet you he would
say in response that he that he's
immunized that that he did his own
research and that he did his own thing
and that that
nobody
that nobody i have a
problem with saying lying because in his
mind again in his mind
he was protected
but he wasn't in compliance and if
you're not in compliance
you can't go walking around floating the
protocols without being punished so
that's why i signed blame not just to
rogers but okay it's one thing for him
to figure hey i know better than dr
fauci i know better than all the
scientists who said that these vaccines
are the best protection because i've
done my own research on youtube
university or wherever it is i got my
information from okay that's on him
but for the people who may have enabled
him
to
perpetuate that
misconception that he was vaccinated
by not holding him accountable when it
comes to protocols
somebody should have either outed him a
long time ago or he should be getting
fine at the wazoo and we just don't know
it but there's no way for anybody he
should be going into press conferences
masculine as if he's vaccinated
and that's on the team in the league
michael smith from brother from another
here on the rich eisen show lots of
conversation as well about another
high-profile top-notch terrific player
in his own right um who has been
far more i guess uh up front about being
vaccine hesitant or resistant um in in
kyrie irving do you think that there has
been a double standard based on the way
that it's been talked about with him and
aaron
michael
i mean i know how pissed off i am and i
think aaron rodgers is worse because
rogers wasn't up front about it at least
kyrie irving had sense enough to explain
himself and he did explain himself
from the comfort of his own home on ig
live
right but also kyrie
knew that his his stance would remove
him from at least half of his team's
games rogers thought that his stance
rogers thought that his stance whatever
he was doing to raise his immunity level
was good enough to stay away from this
virus and potentially not transmit it to
unwitting reporters in the room when
he's maskless right you know where
whereas
now now it's now it's causing his
availability to be affected right but
that that would be the difference to me
if somebody thinks it is a double
standard in terms of so i'm presuming by
your question you mean that aaron is
getting off light i haven't seen that
for what i've seen
i mean as you know aaron is not the most
popular guy with the with the media uh
so i haven't seen him get a pass
compared to kyrie but if he has
i would say the difference is kyrie's
stance
there's a there's a mandate for now
we'll see what the new mayor does
there's a mandate for now in new york
that compromises availability but on the
flip side at least again kyrie agree or
disagree with kyrie which i know you and
i both do
at least kyrie stood on his principles
and and took the criticism that came
with it at least kirk cousins or for
that matter cole beasley
took the criticism that came with it
aaron rodgers and and i got i got some
nuance i'm gonna tag on to this if i if
i may sure aaron rodgers
said i'm immunized
instead of explaining well look i'm not
vaccinated but this is what i went about
doing now again from aaron rodgers
perspective
he's probably sitting up there saying i
don't know y'all jack i don't owe y'all
an explanation we're all learning how to
navigate this new normal he's probably
saying i don't owe you all explanation
as to what i did to take care of myself
because wait for it it's a personal
choice
but here's the thing
and it's like that's why i struggle with
the part about lie
because aaron rodgers what he said on
the 26th was only a lie depending on
your truth
to say that again for the people in the
back aaron rodgers lie on the 26th was
only a lie depending on your truth
and if your truth is that the only way
that you should go about dealing with
this pandemic is to be vaccinated via
pfizer moderner or johnson johnson then
it was a lie
but if you feel like there are
alternative methods to protect yourself
inoculate yourself or immunize yourself
from covert 19
then aaron rodgers told his truth
and i think there's a there's a there's
a nuance and a great that we can live in
without letting him off the hook
for
afterwards violating protocol
so you think maybe the fact that the
packers
are you know doing everything in their
power to keep aaron happy
let him ke keep busting protocol i mean
certainly in the in the media room
because you know there are cameras
everywhere
right and if the league feels that he is
not vaccinated if he's walking around
without a mask
um which we're now we're now in
territory that we we're we're talking
out of our i guess our orifice we don't
know what he's been doing behind the
scenes and assume that the league the
league would slap a fine but the bottom
line is that matt lafleur said that he
as far as the protocol within the
football building they're they're all
buttoned up as far as the protocol in
the media room that's not his that's not
his bailiwick that's what he basically
said no i i agree with all of that i
mean i'm that's why the operative word
is think
i think
right that they've been helping him
cover this up
because from what we've seen he hasn't
been conducting himself as a an
unvaccinated unvaccinated person like
based on a protocol he should have been
at the halloween party great costume i
love john wick
should have been at that party
now not that they can lock him up or
having her medically sealed reads away
from the facility but nonetheless there
are strict protocols for unvaccinated
players that he clearly was in violation
of whether it's the media room or out in
public where we could see him that you
right there are cameras everywhere the
nfl knows if when you went to the
bathroom and and how far you were away
from the next person at the next stall
like they got cameras everywhere and
they should have been finding him so the
real question is
was he being disciplined
when and if he violated protocol behind
closed doors and if he was not why not
because why say he was being enabled
because nobody would have suspected
unless you listen carefully or knew that
he wasn't vaccinated nobody would have
suspected because not only did he say
i'm immunized
in response to that direct question but
he behaved as somebody who was
vaccinated in accordance with nfl rules
so i don't know i don't know for sure
what he's done behind closed doors right
that's to me is the missing piece
because
i don't want to reserve all my
my vitriol for aaron rodgers if the team
and the league was walking on eggshells
with the reigning mvp
michael smith of brother from another
joining me here on the rich eisen show
and again i'm sure this is a topic of uh
discussion with you and michael holly
coming up at the top of the hour as well
as odell um you know you know i i have
no idea what's happening there other
than the fact that odell um
feels
uh that that uh you know he should get
the ball
which every receiver does
um i don't know if he told his dad to
to put out that video of him not getting
the ball right just when the trade
deadline hit i don't know why the browns
didn't trade him i mean just give him
away i mean this makes no sense you
could at least control where he goes now
they can't right they they had that
opportunity now they can't now what they
can just keep him at home which is not
legal for a very long time
i don't know what the hell is going on
man i don't know what's happening but
i'm sure you're talking about what's on
your mind on that subject matter
i mean kevin stefanski might want to
take a page out of uh his division rival
mike tomlins book
you know volunteers not hostages i love
that how great was that sound bite this
was tremendous that guy he's two for two
two straight weeks he's just hitting
home
probably more if we if we really listen
to it all it's like who doesn't miss um
but no it's listen
i don't
i don't know how you feel about parents
especially parents of adult professional
athletes interjecting themselves in in
situations like this
i i just tend to think hit dogs holler
and i'm like if if anybody within the
bronze organization in particular
baker mayfield is offended and he said
he wasn't he said he was surprised but
not hurt for his part he said that with
his own on his own
if anybody has a problem with what
uh odell beckham senior uh the youtube
video he reposted to his instagram
account i mean i would ask first well is
it true
you know i mean is it is the is is the
eye in the sky lying right is odell
beckham running wide open the
quarterback for whatever reason isn't
throwing to them that's problematic and
that should be your issue not that
somebody had the nerve to call it out
number one number two from the bronze
perspective
you know and some people said there was
no trade market for odell beckham i
think we'll see just what kind of market
there is once he's a free agent because
i have to imagine that there's more than
one team that's going to be lined up
willing to there's no question
his abilities here's the thing if you're
the browns this is why you stuck like
chuck
because the browns knowing their heart
of hearts this is an organizational
failure when it comes to not getting
more out of a generational talent i
refuse to believe that this kid is
washed
so it's an organizational failure i know
the previous regime acquired him
but there's no way that he should be
this unproductive they know that he's
going to go somewhere else and make them
look bad
and i think that's all that's what the
reservations are about right now if we
cut him there's going to be a robust
market
for his services as a free agent and
we're going to be paying him the ball
out for somebody else
yeah and you know we had mike silver on
an hour one it was his report yesterday
that nobody in the building is saying
that he has uh created a problem he
hasn't
he hasn't hit the hornet's nest he
hasn't done anything that has been
associated with any if you will prima
donna athlete even though no feelings
i don't know what it is man i don't know
because if you
you you had the ability to if you didn't
want him or he was doing something or
you were pissed about that video right
let's just even say it was the video
let's just even say that's what it was
because or that was a last straw of
stuff going on in the building that we
have not um been privy to right then
then get then then you trade him if you
don't want him showing up somewhere
that is problematic for you like saying
wearing purple and having lamar throw to
him right
so like if you want to prevent that then
you have that opportunity
on tuesday
you correct you didn't do it for
whatever reason
now you say stay home i mean that's not
that's not a long-term answer dude the
texas traded mark ingram to the saints
for like a 20 30 seventh round pick up
some crap i mean it was like i was like
damn they traded them that far out like
it was like you could get something for
him if you want now i know the balance
of the contract could be tricky and
maybe it's a salary cap thing maybe it's
not not that easy right the point being
it's like
you know
he hasn't again we're not in the
building but we haven't heard if if he
were a disruption if he were such a
malcontent we'd have probably heard that
by now because that would have fit in
with what a lot of people conceive of
odell beckham anyway right so we haven't
heard that you're telling me that it's
addition by subtraction to get rid of
odell beckham for an offense that hasn't
cracked 17 points in his last three
games
so that's my thing it's like so the
tipping point was this video
are y'all just embarrassed as you should
be so fix the problem the problem isn't
odell the problem is that you're not
maximizing odell
so they didn't tr and if he was a
problem you're a hundred percent right
rich timing tells all here because if he
were already a problem
they would have done something by the
trade deadline
but what triggered this seems to be the
events of tuesday not just the dad's
video or him reposting the video lebron
that seems to have triggered this entire
sequence of events so now you're going
to release him for nothing behind that
because you're offended because somebody
told the truth about your offensive
operation and his lack of execution as
it relates to its
arguably best receipt probably his best
receiver even coming off the acl so to
me this is just the browns browning
again when we thought they had turned
the page on that
and if he goes somewhere else i i don't
have a hard time believing
that the browns aren't going to end up
with egg on their face
they should have they should have taken
care of this a long time ago but now
i mean what is there to discuss like
what are your options and he seems to be
ready to play
so so you tell me this addition by
subtraction i just find it hard to
believe me too michael great stuff as
always i'm sure it's gonna be a great
show with you and michael holly who else
is on it anybody you want to drop darius
butler okay former cornerback uh with
the colts and and patriots is on the
show as well uh chris sims doing his
usual okay thursday appearance right and
uh yeah i mean there's
kyle there's so much to talk about man i
don't know how i don't know how you've
uh
i don't know how you got it on the show
i'm about to dive into this robert
sarver story real quick i know this is
uh i think i hope i get this right this
is the mike white fan show
things happen to them and that's how
we're going to thank you thank you boy i
i don't know what your clock is and i'll
hold you i want to hear from you because
i'm sorry i haven't listened to this
[ __ ] i want to hear from you yeah like i
think this is fantastic of course it is
it means that the second overall pick
was unnecessary on a quarterback and you
got to move him i think this is
fantastic thank you michael
michael maybe maybe coming from a man
like you that's what i'm saying this
does not
equate what you have inferred what do
you mean that's exactly what i said
michael smith no echoed what brockman
and i were saying exactly which means
mike white's success is a problem for
the jets and i'm saying no who sees the
problem how do you look at it as a
problem god are you serious i don't know
michael he's just he's bugging right now
man
you talking about you talking about you
know how they say this is why we can't
have nice things you talk like somebody
who just doesn't know what a quarterback
looks like since 1968 oh man so it's
like you know like you don't even know
like who cares what round you got him
man if this dude is better than zach
wilson and in one game he looked better
than zach wilson has all season if he's
better than zach wilson then you figure
out the zack wilson problem later and
now you got your quarterback it doesn't
matter how you get one the fact that you
got one or maybe two you're going your
entire lifetime without having to preach
thank you now you might have two thank
you brother smith thank you thanks
thank you for chiming in on that very
important subject is this my last
appearance on this show not at all
there's no canceled culture here there's
no jets canceled culture
all right
michael
smith all right
why'd you wind him up like that
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here